[Music]
okay everybody this is my spoiler review
of everything everywhere all at once
this is written and directed by
daniels and it comes from a24 and i
always excited when i see something from
a24 because it's another
studio that has a good seal of approval
like marvel studios or hbo where you
know you're getting at least quality
maybe it's not always amazing but
there's gonna it's not gonna be terrible
right it's gonna have a seal of quality
on it this is starring michelio and kihi
kwan who i did not know was in the film
which got me really excited because i'm
a huge fan of his when he was a child
actor in the goonies and in indiana
jones temple of doom really cool to see
him as an adult acting it took me a
second to even realize who it was and he
does such a good job here so i went into
this movie not knowing anything all i
knew is that i was getting super praise
and that it was a must see so i kept my
expectations at bay and i was so happy
how much i actually loved this film and
it's one of those films that's a
complete game changer and in a
time when there's so much content that
it stands out as very unique in so many
aspects and
it really is a master class in a lot of
different fields of film in particular
for me editing was the biggest standout
i mean you watch some of these scenes
how they're edited and
you're blown away by what it pulls off
doing that and that
you watch this movie and while you're
watching it whether you love the film or
just like it
you know how much effort was put into
every single shot every detail every
line
that is a movie that you're getting that
you're getting your money's worth that
you should see in theaters because
everything was put into this there's not
one
little ounce of laziness to it it isn't
cheating it is really real and what i
love about it being really real is also
part of daniel's them making this so
confidently meaning they let their humor
really shine here and i didn't expect to
be as funny as it was i was laughing out
loud a lot and
that humor was very strange which i
liked so i'm happy they were confident
enough to do that because that isn't the
most popular type of humor where you're
having hot dog fingers up here which
made me laugh so hard i loved everything
by the way with a hot dog finger
timeline with michellio and jamie lee
curtis that was something i'll never
forget especially the scenes when she's
playing piano with the feet and then
michellio puts her feet up to touch
jamie lee curtis that was just
comedy gold and
a lot of stuff like that happens this
film that's like completely random and
weird especially the whole rat tattooing
reference joke which is great because
it's not even like a recent film but
it's still just hysterical and they had
the raccoon
so so funny and there was humorous
moments that
got the crowd to laugh out loud like
literally a roar which i didn't even
remember experiencing since like borat
won in theaters or people laughing that
hard and those two scenes really were
actually it was just a small moment but
when evelyn
actually wipes her grandpa's snot and
puts it back in his mouth i thought that
was brilliant and also when
we get this fight sequence and these two
guys literally
have
these big plugs coming out of their
butts hanging out of their butts uh and
she's fighting them while it's hanging
out i mean the crowd was going nuts just
of laughter how insane that scene was so
really really awesome now it's
interesting as i was watching the film
it reminded me of one of my favorite
films of all time 2001 a space odyssey
and what i mean by that is that it's
just view of life right how small we are
in such a big universe i got that same
vibe and
it really leans to that and it's funny
because it actually referenced a space
odyssey in the scene with the apes in
this film so you can see that there
definitely was some inspiration there
but i love that
they didn't go as bleak as that in the
sense of they were acknowledging this is
the reality of the world how crazy the
world is with this whole everything
bagel
symbolism going on in all the circles
right everything going from that worked
really well and that
in the end they
still acknowledge that's the world we're
in but it's better to address it by
being kind and that's what really worked
for me because this movie did the
opposite where so many films end with
the big action scene at the end and then
you fight the villain and you kick the
villain's butt and use violence to win
where this saved all its action for the
middle so at the end when you think it's
gonna be this big fight scene she's
actually
killing them with kindness in the sense
right like hugging them you see all
these people are hurting for something
and that being kind is the best way to
go and i like that it showed the husband
wasn't naive that he believed in being
kind too so that really was just a great
message and about how like it real that
film is in the sense of his message that
this is how messed up the world can be
but there is something still to
appreciate about love about being
present about being kind to everybody
and even that the mother and daughter in
their relationship that they couldn't
see eye to eye but just being together
was enough right appreciating that and
that you're never gonna have this
perfect thing where you're totally
synced and that you have to kind of have
just sympathy for each other i thought
was really really just powerful and even
one of my favorite things was the rocks
when they had the mom and the daughter
as the rocks the first time we saw them
as a rocks was probably my favorite
moment of the film how quiet it was and
eerie it was with the captions and it
was the most powerful scene i thought of
the film that conversation the mom and
daughter had as rocks which is just
crazy but it worked but that's what was
really cool was the blend of genres here
from comedy to action a martial arts
film like the kung fu action was awesome
like those sequences looked amazing and
it was really exciting but it was such a
cool blend of genre because it was rapid
fire with the editing where it would go
from serious to action to humor and you
just didn't know what was coming next
and i think that's definitely part of
what kept you on the edge of your seat
now michelio's been being praised a lot
and she totally deserves it just
spectacular here i mean
everything she has to hit here playing
so many versions of her say himself but
different emotions just to play in the
main core of evelyn just hits them all
out of the park so really cool to see
that and i like it had you know meta
references to her with crouching tiger
hidden dragon but also to kiki kwan you
know with the
fanny pack and having the technology
like data from goonies that was that
love letter part of it to those actors
and even they brought in some horror in
it and some stuff that made me really
into this film was really when the
daughter first appears as this jobu
dupaki
character and
that moment when the mom's realizing
that and the fear she has and that
close-up on her and again how it just
shifts then to humor with the everything
bagel being the metaphor i thought was
great and of course jamie lee curtis i
mean transformative part and she just
does what is asked of her and kills it
per usual so that was great too and
now not everything is amazing to me here
i think the only thing i'll bring my
score down a little bit from being a 10
i want it to be a 10
but
there was a couple things i do think
that i don't know if this would take
points off the score but maybe it went
two wilds with the metaverse stuff and
all that traveling and verse jumping for
it to make any sense to any audience i
mean even a smart audience it's a lot i
mean it's almost just too ridiculous at
points where you're kind of like okay
you know what it's better i to enjoy
this one was not even trying to
understand all that i believe so that's
what i did so i don't really hold it
against the film i don't think it was
trying to make it to be so accurate or
understanding but i do think it could
have been a little more easier to grasp
for sure so that was something that took
me off a bit and
the bigger two points though was
i do believe the moment with the
daughter
and her hugging at the end would have
hit harder if i feel like they just gave
a little more time to the relationship
with the daughter of her at the
beginning of the film where i don't
think it was enough i think it was still
so distant for us as the audience to
understand that relationship that it
wasn't given enough time to really get
it and that
took away
from it landing so much and totally
understanding what was really the weight
of the conflict between the mother and
daughter there you get it from a surface
level but i wanted more i want a little
more time to dedicate that to set that
up to pay off more and
my last criticism is it did feel like
the movie was stacking on endings where
it was like
maybe this is where the run time was all
so long too where it was like it felt
like it ended four times and obviously
one time was purposeful it was like a
fake out with the credits which i
thought was great but it just kept going
in these moments that were like dramatic
like learning about the husband and him
not being naive then it would do another
thing and another type of ending feel
like we're just getting like is that it
is that it like it almost played with
your emotions too much or it was like
okay i feel like i've had my cathartic
moment here
and the film you know it kept doing
endings over and over in a sense which i
wasn't crazy about and i think that hurt
just the whole pacing of the film for to
feel like a total masterpiece but i do
think again this is a movie that is
incredible so i'm giving it a 9.6
i
loved it and for me it's definitely the
movie the year so far
for sure and i think it probably will
stay that way and it's going to be tough
to beat but who knows but again editing
acting
is just spectacular and really humor for
me here i laughed so much during this
film which was a treat and i was like i
was not expecting that much from this
type of film so i definitely recommend
it for everybody please let me know your
thoughts in the comments below i'd love
to hear them i read every comment try to
respond as many as i can please make
sure to subscribe you don't miss one of
my movie reviews i also do tv reviews
and celebrity interviews as well and
please follow me at steve varley show on
twitter instagram and tick tock for more
of me and i'll see you next time